je peux pas d'extrême droite en plus je
suis plutôt dans le centre voilà mais je
trouve que le fait que tout le monde ait
le droit de parole c'est le fondement de
la démocratie et heureusement que on
redonne la parole à ceux qui ont des
choses à dire moi je sois d'accord ou
pas avec eux je suis je suis pas pour
par exemple qu'on coupe la chique à
Gilles Verdez je pense radicalement à
l'opposé de ce qu'ils pensent mais il ne
me viendrait pas l'esprit de vous et moi
je veux pas détruit de vos bannir entre
une catégorie vous faites vous faites
des tweets qui énerve des millions de
Français parce qu'ils sont entiers réels
si vous voulez c'est pas pour ça qu'on
va beaucoup plus la chique et votre
problème attendez de courriel fantasmer
les musulmans sont mauvais tous les
immigrésor c'est pas votre réel qui en
France est-ce que vous dites vous savez
le racisme c'est pas une opinion c'est
un délit et le délit il est décrété il
est jugé par la justice c'est pas à une
entreprise privée ou c'est même pas à
des individus qui au prétexte qui sont
choqués par certaines opinions qu'il
rebâtigent ça haine et racisme pour
mieux le censurer vous comprenez ce que
je veux dire c'est la justice c'est un
tribunal qui décide de ce qui est
haineux de ce qui est raciste ou pas
c'est ni agile Verdez ni à ni à personne
moi je n'ai jamais été condamné pour la
haine et d'ailleurs si vous dites que
j'incite à la haine ou que je ou que je
suis dans la haine je peux vous
poursuivre pour diffamation parce que ça
n'est pas le cas je n'ai jamais été
condamné pour ça alors Géraldine toi
c'est non non moi en fait vous
élucubrations et vos pensées en fait je
les connais donc en fait ça ne
m'intéresse pas plus que ça vous tweetez
tant mieux vous Twitter pas tant mieux
tant pis tout va en revanche quand vous
dites Elon Musk vous applaudissez le
messe dès demain en disant c'est
formidable il a rétabli rassurez-moi
vous êtes quand même pour qui
l'interdisent les violeurs les
antisémites les pédocrinels les
terroristes tout à fait on peut se
réjouir
tout ce que vous soulignez là madame
c'est c'est contraire à la loi
l'antisémitisme non qui ça vous vous
avez jamais été condamné pour la haine
ou pour incitation à la haine jamais
vous avez jamais été condamné pour 1500
euros d'amende pour avoir un jury le
préfet des Yvelines a mis des
djihadistes
mais c'est pas une incitation à la haine
et oui mais d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs le problème le procès est en
cours c'est pas définitif donc c'est je
vous permets moi j'ai lu que c'était
définitive non c'est pas définitif donc
vous avez fait appel de la décision
d'accord mais là en première instance on
vous apprend d'aller dans la vie
exactement mais donc c'est très bien en
fait moi
d'amalgame parce que là vous emballez le
truc comme ça toute vitesse un jour
public c'est pas un citation à la haine
c'est c'est
attendez si vous voulez virer tous les
gens qui ont qui ont que la moindre
condamnation de Twitter il va pas rester
grand monde ce que je vous dis c'est que
je trouve ça très bien quand justement
les lois de la République s'empare de
Twitter quand il y a évidemment une
sortie de route et à ce moment-là on est
condamné où on n'est pas condamnés
pour diffamation par Bernard laviradière
il est toujours sur Twitter pourquoi
vous lui dites pas et ben de la même
manière je crois vous avez vous avez une
petite amnésie mais temporaire on parle
de Gilles Verdez
à tout le monde de manière sélective en
fonction de ce que vous aimez
voilà c'est tout
je pense que la plateforme Twitter est
en fait à l'image de cette émission il
faut de la confrontation d'idées pour
faire avancer les choses donc tout
simplement si on lisse Twitter c'est
comme si on lissait cette émission ça
n'aurait plus de sens et ça ne ferait
pas avancer les choses
je précise que ici par exemple quand je
viens je viens pas en terrain conquis
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire mais
Cyril Hanouna a toujours victimiser
le courage d'inviter sur ce plateau et
je dis ça sans flagornerie a toujours le
courage d'inviter sur ce plateau toutes
les opinions toutes les opinions quelles
qu'elles soient la question qu'on nous
pose c'est ce que vous nous avez manqué
honnêtement moi vous m'avez pas manqué
vous vous êtes là c'est bien vous êtes
pas là c'est pas grave mais si tu as une
confidence
en revanche effectivement là-haut ben
oui c'est normal comme ça c'est normal
que vous manque parce que comme ça ça
vous met de la lumière mais du coup j'ai
pas besoin
de lumière à moi tout seul
[Applaudissements]
effectivement moi je suis comme un petit
camarades moi ça me pose aucun problème
que vous ayez le droit de vous exprimer
encore une fois dans le respect de la
loi dans le cadre de de la loi et moi ce
que je veux c'est que les gafams
collaborent avec la loi et c'est pas
toujours le cas et c'est la seule moi
c'est le seul problème que j'ai avec
cette idée de on va remettre en place
tous les bannis et tous les bannis
pourront dire ce qu'ils veulent moi ok
pour rétablir tout le monde si les gars
femme coopèrent réellement et
efficacement avec la loi avec la justice
parce que parfois on a beau leur
demander la justice à beau aller les
chercher la police a beau leur demander
il vous donne pas les adresses IP et
cetera et cetera donc quand de là il y
aura cette égalité là moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord pour qu'il y ait
évidemment une libre parole sur au long
de quoi je c'est une question que je
pose hein au nom de quoi on va interdire
de s'exprimer quelqu'un juste sous le
prétexte qu'il n'est pas d'accord avec
la majorité je suis d'accord avec vous
donc soit on rétablit la liberté
d'expression pour tout le monde moi
personnellement je lutte pour que tout
le monde ait la liberté si demain on
m'annonce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou l'un
des membres de la France insoumise pour
donc pourtant je suis aux antipodes de
l'idéologie et censuré pour des raisons
obscures ce qui a été mon cas je me
battrai pour qu'il puisse respirer